the Trump team is Raging over poll
numbers that increasingly show Donald
Trump failing in swing states where Ron
Des Sanctus is actually doing pretty
well there's a Newsweek article that
summarizes it Donald Trump's campaign
team has dismissed the finding of a poll
that suggests Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis would be the preferred 2024
candidate against Joe Biden in key swing
States the Newsweek article writes a
survey from Republican firm public
opinion strategies shows that DeSantis
who isn't even officially running yet
but is expected to announce soon would
beat Biden in Arizona and Pennsylvania
in a hypothetical 2024 Face-Off by 48-42
and 45 to 42. poll of 500 registered
voters in Arizona and Pennsylvania also
showed Trump would lose to Biden in the
key States if they faced off again in
2024. so the uh the the Trump War Room
account is just attacking the poll they
put out a tweet saying quote public
opinion strategies POS try desperately
for days to try to pitch this fake poll
to other outlets but they refused to
disclose their disclose their ties to
other 2024 candidates and would not
release their cross tabs data truly a
POS poll now I have to tell you the
reality is this is not a unique result
I've been telling you for a while that
the polling suggests that while Trump is
doing really well in the primary polling
DeSantis does better against Biden in
much of the general election polling and
if you take a look at recent polls uh
you see that for example in a morning
consult poll Biden leads DeSantis by one
but Biden leads Trump by three that's a
general election poll if you look at
that uh so then we have the public
opinion strategies poll
um um there's a whole bunch of different
polls you can look at where Biden does
generally better against Trump with a
few exceptions so really the dynamic
here isn't unique to the POS poll most
polls right now suggest that Republican
voters are supporting the guy who would
do worse against Joe Biden and that's a
problem that the Republican party needs
to deal with one or two more of these
and he'll start calling voter fraud a
year and a half out and we'll deal with
that when we come to it but this is this
is a a problem of its own making
DeSantis by all measures would perform
better in a national race against Joe
Biden but can DeSantis actually get
himself into that position the
Republican primary polling increasingly
suggests that DeSantis cannot win a
National primary against Trump and we
are going to continue following those
numbers but the Trump team for now
Furious that anybody would dare to
report on that poll
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
at home for years now I couldn't be more
happy with it I recommend it to
everybody the other day even though
she's not allowed in the big bed I put
my baby daughter on the mattress and
even she loved it Helix sleep is the
premium mattress brand offering tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences take the Helix sleep quiz it
asks you about your body type your
sleeping position do you get hot at
night do you have back pain and then
Helix will match you with the mattress
that's perfect for you most people don't
know where to begin when shopping for a
mattress including me Helix makes it
simple and less risky because you know
you're getting a mattress that fits your
needs it ships free you can try it for a
hundred nights to see if you like it and
it comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty
unlike many mattress companies all Helix
mattresses are made in the USA by a
skilled production team so you were
supporting good jobs helix sleep is
giving my audience up to 20 percent off
plus two free pillows what other
mattress company is going to give you 20
off go to helixsleep.com Pacman the link
is down below